- With Dr. Chambers and Elizabeth Grigsby.
Liz has been to our
conference a number of times,
but for those of you who have not met her,
she is, uh...
Works at the Golden Gate
Regional Center as an advocate.
She's also got a great
voice for civil rights,
and she's gonna talk to
us a little bit today
about some of her...
life as an adult woman
living with cerebral palsy.
- [Dr. Chambers] You okay?
- Yeah.
Good morning.
- [Audience] Good morning.
- At least I think it's still morning.
(light laughter in audience)
Like Gerry said, my name is Elizabeth.
I work for Golden Gate
Regional Center as an advocate.
Yes, I get paid to work there.
(light laughter in audience)
Yes, I do have cerebral palsy from birth.
It's never a dull moment.
(audience laughs)
I do live in my own place.
And I don't have 24-hour support,
because I don't need it.
And I don't want it.
(light laughter in audience)
People get on my nerves.
(audience laughs)
I'd rather be around my two cats.
(light laughter in audience)
They don't talk back.
(audience laughs)
Hopefully Dr. Chambers will
ask me a bunch of questions
(Dr. Chambers laughs)
about how it is living with CP.
- Yeah, so what would you say
your biggest challenges were
going from high school to
your post high school years?
- Well, I know my biggest challenge
from elementary up to high school.
- Okay, there was a big
problem at that point?
- The biggest problem was I have,
I didn't get the physical
therapy that I needed.
I heard some people talk about CCS,
and the videos look really good.
But I'm like, what the
hell happened to me?
(scattered laughter)
I can tell you what happened to me.
My foster mother didn't want me to get
the physical help that I
needed, because she was afraid
the more independent I became,
I wouldn't need her anymore,
which was pretty messed up.
Because I think I would've...
went a long way physically if I had got
the physical therapy when I was little,
but neither here or there.
- [Gerry] So I think you're
bringing up a really good point,
Liz, that we all have to
keep in mind that people have
very different lives, when
we see them outside of,
in their home, and in their everyday life,
and some people have much
more support than others.
- By the way, this is my
primary nurse practitioner,
which I love.
- [Gerry] (laughs) She
says that every year, yeah.
(audience laughs)
- That's why she gets to come back.
- That's why we ask her back, all right.
(audience laughs)
- And she doesn't even pay me to say that.
- That's a good question.
So you're working as a consultant.
What do you do for
people whose parents have
different ideas, parents
or the clients themselves,
have a different idea than what you think
is the right thing for them?
- Parents are, I love
you guys who are parents.
You guys are really awesome.
But parents with people with disabilities,
I do have to be honest,
you are a thorn in my side.
(audience laughs)
Because you're all like,
"My son can't do this."
Or, "My daughter can't do this
"because they have a disability."
I'm here to say that's BS.
The only disability is that
you don't want to let them go.
You don't want to let
them fall and get back up,
and fall again, and it's like I'm scared.
But what's gonna happen
when you pass away?
You hold on to them really tight,
they're not gonna know how
to make it on their own.
So I'm here to tell you
if you're in Golden Gate
Regional Center's kids main
area, don't let me hear about
your not wanting your son or
daughter becoming independent,
'cause you're gonna have hell to pay,
(audience laughs)
which you're gonna have to deal with me.
And don't let the wheelchair
fool you, I'm not that nice.
(audience laughs)
- [Gerry] I told you she had a voice.
- Let me ask you a question, though,
because this is a serious
one because it happens to me
every day, and also for
our CCS people here.
What about the families
that say I would like
to have therapy not five days a week,
but could we do it twice a day?
And that's a real, that's a real problem.
Especially when we have less resources,
and also, is that bad?
Is it bad to have that much extra work?
- You know, there is something
coming up in California
called self-determination.
And a person who doesn't
like the traditional services
from the regional center, they can sign up
for self-determination,
and they will be allotted
some money where they
can buy into services
that the regional center is
not able or willing to pay.
I'm gonna just keep it real.
I love working for the regional center,
but sometimes we get
into this bureaucracy,
and we always say we can't
do this, or can't do that.
I'm sick of hearing the word can't.
It's time to start saying
we can, and we will.
'Cause that's a...
(applause)
that's a basic human right.
- [Gerry] And I'll just
say also, it's good to have
advocates and people
who can help negotiate,
and there are some stark realities
that we have to deal with
in terms of resources,
but that is a good point.
- I've been an advocate for
myself pretty much all my life.
I had to prove myself
to non-disabled people
on an every day basis.
Hell, I'm still doing it.
Do you know how tiring that gets?
That gets really tiring.
When I go see Gerry,
and I love her office,
but sometimes the people
there talk to me like I'm,
like I'm stupid or something.
They're like, either
they talk really loud,
or very babyish, and they're like,
"Can you stretch your arm out?!"
(audience laughs)
And I'm like, "I could, if
you stop yelling in my ear."
(audience laughs)
Or even when I'm working
at the regional center,
and I've been working
there for over 21 years,
and I still get from
some of my co-workers,
like the other day, this
social worker was like,
"Liz, Elizabeth, where's your nurse?"
And I'm like, "I don't have a nurse."
"Sure you do, where's
the lady that's with you
three days a week?"
"You mean my job coach?"
"But I thought, I could've
sworn you had a nurse."
And I'm like, that's
the problem with people,
they always assume.
Don't assume.
It makes you look stupid.
(audience laughs)
I'm sorry, it makes
you look really stupid.
And I get tired of educating you.
It's like, do I really have
a disability, or do you?
(laughter and applause)
- We could keep asking
questions, but y'all are here
for this, any questions
that you'd like to ask Liz?
- The biggest disability
is people's attitude.
That's what makes, I
suffer from depression.
Like Dr. Chambers was saying earlier...
A lot of us have depression.
I'm just keeping it real.
You know why we have depression?
'Cause nine times out of
ten, people aren't seeing us
for regular people.
They want to see us as disabled bodies.
We didn't wake up one morning and say,
"Oh, I love having CP.
"Oh, I love having down syndrome,"
or whatever your disability may be,
but if people's attitude
make you feel like
you've done something wrong,
it's time to change that.
'Cause like Dr. Chambers says, again,
we're all gonna be
disabled, whether you want
to face it or not.
You're able bodied now, but you won't be
in a couple of years.
So take heed of that.
- Sounds like a threat, is that a threat?
(audience laughs)
- Hey, I need to travel
around with you, Dr. Chambers.
Both of us together, we
would be very lethal.
(loud laughter)
- Can I be Mel Gibson?
(light laughter)
- I would love to give up my
job and just travel with you,
and talk to stupid people.
(audience laughs)
- [Audience Member 1] I have a question.
I noticed your reaction to
Dr. Chamber's comment about
transportation being a problem.
- Oh yeah.
- [Audience Member 1] So tell
us what are the worst parts
of the transportation problems.
- So, let me ask the question
again for the other people.
So what are the worst parts
that you've encountered
with the transportation
problems, I would assume,
in San Francisco?
- You know what the worst
part is about transportation?
When I have a doctor's appointment,
and I'm waiting for my van...
and Gerry is so patient,
but I'm not that patient.
I'm like, "Where the hell is the van?"
(audience laughs)
And when they get there,
they act like it's your fault
that they're late, and
they're always like,
"Get on the van."
I'm like, I have a disability.
You can't rush somebody with CP.
We have spasms, and if my hand goes wild,
the control goes wild, and
if the control goes wild,
I'm gonna end up running you over.
(audience laughs)
Well, maybe I'll run you over just because
(loud laughter in audience)
you deserve it, and you
annoy the hell out of me.
And that doesn't have
nothing to do with my CP.
I love how people tell me,
"Oh honey, it's just your CP."
It's like, not everything
that's wrong with me is my CP.
You're my problem, and
you're not part of my CP.
(audience laughs)
So what do you think about that?
- [Gerry] So part of the
reality that I think, too,
is there are lots of
medical issues to deal with,
and transportation can,
there's a number of things,
transportation can be an issue.
Getting an appointment with
a specialist can be an issue.
- Getting on the table
to have a pap smear.
- [Gerry] Getting on the
table, even though I have
an adjustable table, getting on the table
was quite a chore this year, wasn't it?
- Yeah, just a couple weeks
ago, we got the Hoyer Lift.
I miss the lifting.
I'm very mad at UC for
getting rid of the lifting.
Not only was it fast and strong
to have two guys lift me,
but they were cute too, you know.
(loud laughter)
I'm just like, they just
ruined my whole day.
(audience laughs)
But having the Hoyer
Lift, so I get strapped up
to the Hoyer Lift, fine.
We go out in the hall, I get
hooked up to the Hoyer Lift,
finally after these two people
figured out how to use it.
So I get hooked up, I'm like, "Okay we're,
"we're cooking with gas now."
(light laughter in audience)
They go press the button to lift me up.
The damn thing stops.
I'm in mid-air, and they're
like, "Oh, the battery died."
(audience laughs)
What the feh?
(loud laughter in audience)
- [Gerry] We'll try to bleep,
can we bleep that out, John?
(laughs loudly)
- You can't make this stuff up!
Even if I try, I'm looking at Gerry,
she's looking at me.
I'm looking at one of
my staff, I'm like...
"Okay."
(loud laughter in audience)
I'm cool, I'm calm, I'm cool.
And they're like, "Oh,
don't worry, we just
"have to run across the street
and get another battery."
I'm like, "Oh, don't mind me."
(audience laughs)
"I'll just hang here,
like I have a choice."
(audience laughs)
"But don't mind me, I love
having my hips separated.
"Even though one of them
happens to be dislocated,
"but I'm happy to be hanging up here.
"You just go and take
your slow, sweet time."
(audience laughs)
"I'm not going nowhere."
- [Gerry] It was the longest
pap smear that I've done
in my history of, uh--
- No the longest pap smear you did is when
one of my staff fainted.
- [Gerry] Yes, that was, uh.
(audience laughs)
Yep, right, I forgot about that.
Yep, (chuckling) we've
had some really good
experiences over the years.
(audience laughs)
So you can see why we
attract so many people
to go into primary care.
(laughs)
- I know you probably don't believe that.
- [Gerry] It's true!
- But yeah, she was holding my leg up.
Gerry was doing her thing,
and the next thing you know,
she's about to fall on the floor.
Gerry had to catch her...
(laughter in audience)
and ease her down.
And then Gerry called the,
called the, the ambulance.
They came, and they're
banging on the door,
and Gerry said, "You can't come in."
(loud laughter)
- [Gerry] We just dragged
her out and put her,
no, we didn't do it.
(audience laughs)
- And they're like, "What do
you mean we can't come in?"
'Cause I have my pants down!
(audience laughs)
I'm indisposed!
And they're all like, they
thought I was the patient.
No, no, no!
I didn't faint, one of my staff did.
Because, why?
She didn't eat all day that day.
How stupid can you get.
(audience laughs)
And they say I have a disability.
You don't know how it is being in a chair,
having to depend on people
for everyday, basic needs.
It's...
It's crazy.
Does anybody have any questions?
(audience laughs)
- [Gerry] Can I first say,
I did get endocervical cells
on the pap smear, though,
despite that being two hours?
Okay?
- Well, that's because
you're one hell of a--
- [Gerry] (laughs)
I'm persistent, if nothing else.
- Yes.
- Nevertheless.
- [Audience Member 2] Hi, Liz.
- Hi. I know you, you're my co-worker.
- [Audience Member 2] I wanted
you to touch a little bit
on what reactions you
get when you tell people
that you enjoy having alcohol--
(bursts of air into microphone)
- So the question was,
how do you tell people
or what reaction do you
get when you tell people
that you are a person...
(light laughter in audience)
essentially, who likes to have fun,
go out on dates, have a life?
- I can answer that question.
It amazes people when
I tell them that people
with disabilities can have sex.
They're all like, "Oh my god, but how?"
(audience laughs)
I'm like, do you really want me to...
explain it to you?
I mean, I can.
We can have a full hour
conversation how it works.
One gets on top of the other one.
(audience laughs)
And then, you know, we take it from there.
But when I do drink, yes I drink,
I used to drink to hide my pain.
I'll admit it.
I was a drinker to hide my depression.
But I have, I've been seeing
a therapist for a while now.
And it's been, it's really helpful.
I'd recommend everybody
to see a therapist.
Even if you don't have a
depression or whatever.
We all need somebody to talk to.
Let's keep it real.
But when I go out to clubs...
Well, I don't go as much as
I used to, but when I drank,
people were like, "But, but you have CP."
And I'm like, "Yeah, but
you know, the alcohol
"relaxes my muscles."
So, it does really.
I'm not kidding.
I don't abuse it no more.
But it does relax my
muscles, and I tend to drive
my chair much better...
(audience laughs)
when I'm a little bit intoxicated.
(Gerry laughs loudly)
(audience laughs)
- At least you think you do.
- [Gerry] (laughing) Yeah!
- Well, I think I do very good.
I know how to parallel park
like nobody's business.
(audience laughs)
- Somehow, I get better looking.
I think that's a really important point,
and it's not just in adults.
You have to start asking your 13 year olds
if they drink alcohol, and
it's one of those things
you can't do in front of the parents.
And there's a certain
point, I and one of my other
physiatrists, we ask the parents to leave.
And about 13 year olds, and
we ask them those questions
about alcohol, drugs, other
behavior, sex behaviors
that might need contraceptive
or even be tested.
So those are things that, it's hard to do.
And parents, like you
said, parents do not want
to be out of the room.
And sometimes there are
some communication problems,
but usually these are
the kids that are maybe
ambulatory kids who you
think are doing really well,
and then when you finally
talk to them, they're doing,
"Oh yeah, I drink every
Saturday," or something like that.
Or "I do a lot of marijuana."
That's the biggest one that I've seen now.
Even before it became legal,
there were a lot of kids
that would use a lot of
marijuana as a relaxant
and also just like any
other teenager, I guess.
- Doctor, can I ask you a question?
- Sure.
- So you said, if I understand correctly,
you said CP does change
over the years, right?
'Cause when I was younger...
I must've been around 10, maybe nine,
the doctor I would see was like,
"CP is never gonna change,
you're gonna maintain
"your mobility, don't worry about it."
And the older I got, I was like,
I can't turn over like I used to.
What does he mean it's never gonna change?
So I kept getting tighter, my muscles,
and I was just like,
the doctor lied to me.
And that brought on my depression, too.
Because here, this doctor's telling me,
"Oh you don't have to worry
about it, it's never gonna,
"it's not gonna get any worse."
- Yeah, I think what most
people are, just maybe,
they misinterpret, is that
the brain problem, the lesion
that you had when you were
born, shouldn't change.
I think it changes a little bit,
but it shouldn't change much.
But the outward
manifestations, the tightness,
the motor problems, the hips coming out,
that all gets worse.
- Yeah, my left hip, they
put it in a bunch of times,
and it always comes back out.
So I was like I'm done, no more surgeries,
I'll just keep it like it is.
- Yeah.
- And yes, it does hurt a lot.
When I, especially when
I'm in my shower chair.
And I take, I want to take long
showers to relax my muscles,
but then I can't sit that
long, because my leg goes numb
and my hips start to hurt really bad.
- Yeah.
- Somebody has a question.
- Yeah, one last question.
- [Gerry] One or two more
questions, and then we're,
gotta wrap up.
- [Audience Member 3] I'm a
pediatrician in a rural area,
and my question is, and
our nearest rural center
is three-and-a-half hours
away, would you rather
have a well-meaning and willing to
(breathing in microphone)
as your primary care,
and most of your care,
or would you rather take
the three-and-a-half hour
car ride to see a specialist?
- So the question is, if you
were living in a rural area
where this pediatrician's
living, would you rather
have a well-meaning doctor
who's gonna try to do
everything they can for
you, or would you rather
take the three-and-a-half
hour drive to see
some specialist who might
know a little bit more
about the problem?
With all the transportation issues.
- I'd rather see the one person...
than have a longer time
to have to sit on the van,
not knowing when I'm gonna get there,
and when I do get there,
no problems, the doctor,
but they might not have
the time to see me.
So I'd rather, I'd rather, um...
try my luck with the
doctor who doesn't know
as much about CP, and we
figure it out together, than...
'Cause if people would
listen, that's the thing.
Doctors need to listen
more to their patient.
If people will listen, the
person with the disability
can tell you how they're
feeling, or what their
physical needs are.
You just need to take
the time and stop asking
the person that they're with,
like they're not the patient.
- [Gerry] Great, thank you so much, Liz,
for being with us today, and Dr. Chambers.
(applause)